merkel y es back un anuncio esperado
ante un escenario internacional y de
forma virtual desde el regreso de
acuerdo de parís hasta la reactivación
del diálogo con irán es oficial eeuu
vuelve a estrechar sus lazos con
occidente fue el mensaje de job aid en
la conferencia de seguridad de múnich un
mensaje en recibido con alivio las cosas
van a mejor en gran manera para el
multilateralismo este año respecto a
hace dos años y eso tiene mucho que ver
con que joe biden se haya convertido en
el presidente de los eeuu de américa
unoamérica día de peso en la agenda
internacional porque al margen de la
conferencia de múnich también hubo
reunión del g7 las siete potencias que
manejan poco menos de la mitad de toda
la economía mundial
estos países se comprometieron a
impulsar la economía internacional en
medio de la crisis por la pandemia
también buscan asistir a las naciones en
desarrollo para que avancen en sus
planes de vacunación con una ayuda de
hasta el 5 por ciento de su actual
distribución de los antídotos creo que
si queremos lograr este multilateralismo
que produzcan resultados el desafío que
tenemos enfrente es entre
estadounidenses y europeos
a todos los países del mundo pobres y
emergentes acceder de manera más rápida
posible al diagnóstico y también a las
vacunas y a mejorar su sistema de salud
pero hay un contrapeso a esta alianza ya
los desafíos con rusia puede que sean
diferentes a los de china pero son igual
de reales no se trata de poner al este
contra occidente no es que queramos un
conflicto queremos un futuro en donde
todas las naciones puedan determinar
libremente su propio camino sin una
amenaza de violencia o coerción es un
pulso que ya está en marcha
tanto moscú como beijing han aprovechado
su distribución de las vacunas para
expandirse internacionalmente desde
áfrica hasta latinoamerica evidenciando
en el caso de la unión europea un
fracaso en su industria farmacéutica